ils ont préparé l'hôpital notre dame à
la pandémie
plusieurs de ces médecins spécialistes
se disent maintenant prêts à travailler
dans les sièges celle des infectés c'est
sûr que je vais y aller je m libre la la
cool si les gens m'interpellent qui on a
vraiment besoin de moi je suppréssion
bourgeois est un bon soldat à 55 1 et
malgré un problème pulmonaire stanley
vollant et prêts à plonger en ch et
celle des mais ça veut dire qu il
délaissera des tâches importantes à
l'hôpital il ya j'ai fait de l'instance
opératoire pour un groupe complexe de
cancer de l'intestin
donc on travaille très fort on
interprète occupée malgré leurs
connaissances pointues
ces spécialistes rappellent qu'ils n'ont
pas d'expertisé dans les soins aux
personnes âgées
j'ai aucune idée de comment déplacer un
patient de façon sécuritaire de propre
comment prendre les bonnes précautions
pour le faire même chose pour je veux
pas remplacer d'infirmières du tout je
peux je peux la suite puis samedi au
québec offre aux besoins premiers les
signes vitaux ok je prends les courses
je suis à pas faire ça chez comment
faire ça mais pour tout le reste une
formation que je n'ai pas et préviennent
que s'ils sont contaminés en csld
d'autres patients à l'hôpital vont
écoper
les études vont reprendre ainsi tous les
mêmes les chirurgiens et les insistons
malades
ben on voit tomber dans le trop mon
pourront même pas opérer des gens qui
ont une espérance de vie très très
longue
on va laisser mourir comme d'autres
infirmières josé charrette veut
travailler en 6 h et celle des mais
l'établissement qu'elle visait ne peut
obtenir de référence de ses anciens
patrons probablement débordé par la
crise actuelle étant donné qu'ils sont
pas capables de rejoindre deux
références ils m'ont dit mais madame on
ne fait pas suite à votre demande
d'emploi et je ne suis pas engagé preuve
que la situation est critique
québec lancé un appel à tous les
étudiants dans les programmes de santé
et de services sociaux des cégeps et des
universités pour qu il s'enrôle
immédiatement comme préposé pour
bénéficiaires ici david gêne-t-il
radio-canada bon gars